[موسيقى]
تقريبا من زمان بيتي مناظر كله لان اني
فنانه فلازم يعني يطلع بيت كل الرسومات
يعني نسوي متحف نسوي رسومات مثلا هيك وانا
بس مو بيتي يعني عندي رسم يعني هسه عندي
متحف هنا عندي زي القرش مشكل اثوري عندي
هندي
جلابيات يعني عندي كل شيء اهلي هم شجعوني
وبالنسبه انا
كان يعجبني الرسم
حبيته عاشقه فن
هذا متحف مالتي
يعني
الشيء كله يدوي
قصص هم القرش كله قصص يعني مثلا هاي خانه
قديمه
قاعدين يلعبون يشربون شاي القهوه
هذا راعي الغنم
بس الشتاء هيك يلبسوا كان يلبسون راعي
الغنم
الزواج قبل
البنات كانوا يلبسون شابات
وهذولا كل واحد هو وزوجته
هاي قديمه كانوا ياخذون من بير خلق قبل ما
كان أكل مثلا
يقول لا اني اول واحد فصارت عركه بيناتهم
هاي يوم راح تاخذ المي من بئر خطيره راح
تاخذ
نار بالخشب
حياه الغش قديمه بالنسبه لنا هيك كانوا
يعني
تسوي حب راح تيجي بنتها يما احد مثلا كل
احد تجي بنتها يما هذا مالك فيصل
هاي الصوره من زمان يا امي هي
تقريبا عندها خمسين سنه هذولا هاي عندها
اربعين سنه يعني مثلا قديمه كلش امي
مثلا بنت اخوي كان ابتدائيه هي سوت هاي
امي هسه بنت اخوي باستراليا مدرسه هي
هذول عندهم 100 سنه
بالنسبه لهذول بنت من كانت تتزوج مثل
هذولا كانت خطيه هذا يسمون يعني اسمه اسمه
الماضي
هذولا
لازم نحافظ هذولا قديمه كلش 100 سنه
هذا اسمه يعني احنا
عندي قلب مغربيات
سوريات كرديات كرديات خليتوهم بالكرتون
هاي كل القوشيات كلهم هذول القرشين
يعني يلبسون مثلا راح تجي هسه عيد
الصعانين فيجون من خارج كل يلبسون يطلعون
بالكنيسه مثلا يجوني اطفال امهات وما
يعرفون يلبسون ما يعرفون
حتى الشباب ما يعرفون
كلاني
الطفل عشر سنوات خمس سنوات من سنوات
تقريبا
هذا الولد
عندي مال امي هاي
هذا ابد ما نبيعه هاي كانت تسوي خطيه هي
اثنين اثنين بالنهار
هسه
بالنسبه لهذولا مليانه دهوك بس انا الا
بيدي الا شغل ايدي
هذول كرديات
يعني مره تلبسون ويا كردي
اكو هوايه بس انا الا بيجي شغل ايدي
[موسيقى]
كان سوينا البرغل ماكينه على السطح هاي
خيمه مال العرب سويتوها بدون لعبات اقمشه
القماشه حتى يجبل البشر سويتهم
يعني مثلا القماش قماش شويه يشبه البشر
مثلا سويتهم
[موسيقى]